more than two years after he was sent to
prison we have a new look at bill cosby
behind bars
and the image is both sad and disturbing
at the same time
cosby is grinning looking down and a
white face mass is hanging from his neck
this latest mug shot of the disgraced
comedian was taken in september
and just released today so why the new
photo
a prison rep tells e.t that inmates get
new mug shots every once in a while
as their appearance changes and cosby
was due for a new one
in fact in just the two years since his
last prison photo
cosby appears more disheveled and to
have aged
considerably back in march the 83 year
old's lawyers tried to get him an early
release from prison
after a covet 19 outbreak inside the
facility where he's staying
that was denied cosby's hoping to
overturn his conviction in december
when his appeal goes before the
pennsylvania supreme court
let's move on to the day's other big
story oscar winner jeff bridges has
revealed
he has cancer the 70 year old was upbeat
and in good spirits with us
at last year's golden globes i feel
young inside i
still feel like a young pup jeff shared
his cancer news in the kind of laid-back
style made famous
by his character in the big lebowski
quote as the dude would say
new blank has come to light i'm the dude
i have been diagnosed with lymphoma
although it is a serious disease
i feel fortunate that i have a great
team of doctors and the prognosis is
good
i'm starting treatment i don't think
there's a cause for panic the numbers
are in his favor we don't know which one
he has but
it's 86 percent for hodgkin it's 70
percent for non-hodgkin that's the
five-year survival rate those are pretty
darn good numbers compared to some other
[Music]
cancers